welcome to serious jibber jabber i'm
here with four friends and former
colleagues of mine from the simpsons
four writers that helped lay the
foundation for a tv series that has the
distinction of being the longest running
prime time animated series of all time a
program that time magazine called the
best television series of the 20th
century
the simpsons has received 27 emmys
30 annies and was the first animated
series to be given a peabody award most
importantly it's been discussed within
the hallowed halls of the vatican
apparently is that true i didn't even
know that was true yeah i got a blessing
from
the the pope that resigned
you're blessing us
i must i'll bless you all now al jean hi
mike reese jake hogan jeff martin uh and
then there's me stinky
um let me start with and this will be
very free-ranging and informal obviously
but let me just start with
there's this thing that happens where
now and a show like the simpsons seems
inevitable you know it's just become
this cultural touchstone and people say
of course
and what i'm trying to do is go back to
a time when it was highly improbable and
probably even considered a bad idea
the last successful animated show had
been the flintstones
and uh i guess i'll i'll start with you
guys who were there at the very
beginning
uh
suddenly the idea comes along on fox to
do an animated
prime time show
and
i don't think people thought it was a
good idea is that right what happened
was one of the directors david silverman
who's brilliant uh
was at a party and he did a little too
much to drink and he said to jim brooks
i think it should be a series and he was
so emphatic and so
enthusiastic about doing another
primetime series you know there's never
been one like you said for years but jim
said well if somebody loves this so much
why don't we give it a shot and um
you know then jim and matt and sam simon
hired writers and uh it was never
inevitable in addition to that i will
just say that at the tracy almond show
we used to
uh show the simpsons
back to back
the little shorts back to back to the
audience and they laughed
significantly more than they actually
left the tracy omen show i mean it was
clear it was clear that this had
potential this was something i think you
didn't need a drunk david silverman to
say oh my god i think we that we oh no
it was
but it's true they saw it they
cut it together and they showed it and
it took everybody who would say who saw
it would said this this has success
written all over it but anyone else who
never saw that said you're an idiot for
doing the show well the other thing is
let's go back to fox at the time
uh now we live in a world of a thousand
channels and fox is actually uh you know
become a very dominant network and had a
lot of success but at the time
uh animated series fox uh it seemed like
a probably a very improbable idea right
the first episode they came back i guess
you should just being the one person
here that was there at that meeting
well i could do a few things one is my
father's a tv comedy writer when he said
when i said to him i want to go work on
this animated tv show he said you're
nuts don't ever do that you'll ruin your
career
and it's uh
and
the only reason i didn't
listen to him because he's a very smart
guy is i'd seen people actually laughing
at it really hard and wally and i my
writing partner matt schwartz the little
shorts said we have to do this show
because we thought sam simon's genius
and matt greening you know
has an interesting uh comic strip and we
didn't know him very well even though we
worked at the tracy holman show together
we didn't know but that was
that seemed to us incredibly probable
but to everyone i ever talked to
including people like grant tinker who
told wally and i don't do it and a lot
of people said it's going to be a
disaster um and and when we saw the
first show of the simpsons a babysitter
abandoned it's like it was
uh what was wrong with it because also
the show evolved i mean when i see
a very early simpsons now i noticed dan
castlenetta had a yeah he was trying to
almost do walter matthau right it isn't
frosty chocolate milkshake yeah it
wasn't quite there yet i mean it was it
was close this is something uh
uh jeff and i used to talk about at
that's your old friend jeff jeff martin
no
no something no you're not you're not
who i thought you were i don't know who
his voice is
this is something jeff and i used to
talk about you would make the point that
it's very rare
in television or music for all the
components to be right
from the beginning do you know what was
our other example i thought it was
batman batman was the other example you
and i would talk obsessively about
batman but just the casting of the
original batman series in the 60s the
writing the graphic look everything was
perfect from the get-go first episode
from the very first episode and i think
it's the same thing that we just talked
about with the simpsons is that
the the voices uh were impeccably cast
from the beginning the design i mean
really all of them were in the shorts
the main ones dan
it was dan and julie dan kessler and
julie kevin there were on the tracey
allman show and as i understand it tracy
allman was too busy to do any of the
parts so she hated it as well she hated
it she really yes
she hated she hated the cartoons oh yes
she wanted it off the show right and uh
and then later on she sued for money
because she said i i breastfed these
babies and these were from my from my
show like she had nothing to do with it
and i
actively tried to get it get it off the
show so uh for the rest of us
the rest of us have no opinion on what
you've just said jay kogan however of
102 bird songway but but nancy
cartwright was also
found as a voice for the shorts and the
arresting director
who uh asked i think nancy to read for
lisa and lee harley smith to read for
bart ironically and they
you know both said you know nancy said
hey i do this boy voice which is just
she's been doing it since she was i
asked her when she started she was 18 i
think and she also does nelson and ralph
like amazing channeling of a
ten-year-old boy she's just a genius and
then um harry and shira and hank's area
came in when we did the series but the
but not very hank came late there was a
whole other guy
who did mo and uh and then they looped
him out i don't know what happened
in the series that people saw but that's
right and then there was uh there's some
we went to that first reading and tom
first guy to sue us
this tv psychiatrist this radio
psychiatrist was there at the reading
playing the radio psychiatrist and he
sort of got fired in the middle of the
reading it was just awful to watch
it all came together quite easily and
magically right away it kind of it's
belied by the fact that it didn't come
together quite that easily yeah it was
supposed to come on in september right
we they waited until we had an episode
of the christmas episode which came out
was the first really rock solid by sober
david silverman
referred to from now on and it seemed
like reasons it came out of the gate
boom fantastic but that was episode
seven right i mean that was part of it
was since they didn't premiere in the in
the fall they said what's another good
one to premiere with and it just
happened to be the christmas show
and uh
then the second one there was also
directed by david barth the genius yeah
and david has been with the show the
whole time well you guys were there uh i
remember just as an outsider i was
working at starting out live at the time
and were you you were at letterman i was
at letterman yeah and there was a
instantaneous kind of explosion
everybody was talking about it um it
wasn't only popular but it was respected
by
comedy nerds which is
doesn't happen often so you used to
crave yeah
it was like six weeks in it was the
cover newsweek that was amazing the
other thing is they teach i've read a
bunch of simpsons books and
theses about the show and they'll always
say the show was slow to build and had a
small following and the show debuted to
the highest ratings in the history of
the fox network that was the christmas
episode yeah it came on it was an
instant i mean nothing could be a more
instant hit right but it was also i mean
i remembered all of us gathering around
gathering around to watch episodes at
saranet live when it would come on
instantly because everybody knew this
was
the show and we were delighted by the
writing and
whatever happened to saturday night live
it's very sad
lauren michaels like the letterman show
long gone yeah
starting out live letterman all ghosts
from the past
i had i was like ringo i had perfect
timing
i got on right after they got the
recording contract but it was they they
uh it
i'd written for letterman for six years
and sam simon got in touch with me and
he'd seen a packet of letterman stuff
and asked if i might want to do it and
like
oh like while i'm contemplating it it
goes on the air and it's an instant
smash and like two weeks later i'm going
to move out to la and just before i move
out to la uh
uh bart the general yeah was on the air
yeah and i'm watching it and it was just
like it was the nicest feeling because
we were on the shandling show which was
also on fox and it was the lowest rated
show on the air so we're sitting there
going what is the difference
jerry we're gonna go over here
this is where your harvard education
kicked in lowest rated eyes rated
what to do i have a math degree but it
wasn't a big part of like watching the
beatles or or star wars or some crazy
phenomenon yeah people were selling
shirts off of highway phenomena was so
much was was so much bart centric yes
it's sort of forgotten
we were talking about that but something
in nancy cartwright's voice some quality
in it and how the character looked and
what it said just everyone said you know
it was like tina fey doing sarah palin
yeah where just the whole world went
that's great yes
people even go now they go so when did
you as the writers make the decision to
shift from bart to homer and i say we
never had any conscious long-term plan
over anything it was just probably that
that as we aged or you know we thought
of homer stories more easily than bart
stories
so it's a 10 year old boy there's never
been much he can do or could be a law
order guy
no i'm a hippie i remember he can have a
different
different fascination well there was one
episode where humber said like no marge
i'm a farmer that's the kind of guy i am
this week
he had a list
of all his professions that he had where
marge went up and brushed his teeth and
came back to bed and he still hadn't
finished that was season 13.
people uh
people always come up to me and they
know that i uh worked on the simpsons
and they want to know about it and i the
best i can do is explain to them that
it's the exact opposite of what i do in
my late night career meaning
the late night career
for almost 20 years now has been
think of it patch it together get it on
the air and
barely rehearse it throw it out there
and uh you know yes
you know and it's basically just it's
vaudeville it's and it's every night and
it's a disposable pen
this experience on the simpsons was
from the first time you pitch it and you
work it in the room and then you go back
and you work on it again and then the
room breaks it apart and works on it
again there's about 18 stages where
you're going through and with
you get to the point where it's fine
little filing tools and
sometimes there's a joke that's worked
35 times throughout the process but it
doesn't work the 36th time and it comes
out and is replaced with an inferior
joke
gentlemen
condemn your process
it sounds like we're
[Laughter]
is
it's all democratic i always call it
like a lapocracy where it's welded a
joke a joke goes in because somebody
says it and
more than half the people in the room
laugh right and that's when we screen
the shows and jokes these in if it makes
the room laugh it's never just somebody
going i think this is good or
no the other thing too is i had come
from uh
it's a it's a
started out live
probably different than late night shows
in that there was real estate getting
something on the air was really prized
so the writers could be very competitive
and one of the things i always
appreciated about the simpsons was that
everybody wanted the best joke everybody
also wants to go home
and so when someone gets the right joke
there's a unanimous uh wave of joy and
yay you did it there's not a competitive
feeling i think it's accurate to the
borg and star trek where it's really
this i don't know what you're talking
about
with my mind
tell the nerds what that is it's a joke
venn diagram of conan fans and star trek
fans is swap sports schools yeah while
you're doing that
by the way why do you get that cup
uh oh greg daniels made this cup it's a
replica of a cupcake daniels
[Laughter]
greg made this cup for me from my first
uh late night show and it had just a
list of crazy words that i would mutter
and um this is like a replica of a
replica of a replica the original is in
the smithsonian in the trash at the
smithsonian can i tell one story about
something yeah jubjubs on this yes and i
remember one time it was just we were
talking about how the need the shows had
so much material in them that you you
said you know everything goes into this
vortex like you know jub job there now
that it exists it will go in the show oh
yeah i just made up a word jubjub and i
said this show feeds on anything that's
in the atmosphere and i said jubjubin
not long after that very soon after i
think you said it more than once yeah i
said a lot
i think i did for saying a lot but i was
just saying cleaner story the way i
remember it let's let's workshop this
story
but i mean and then jump jump because
soon
one of marge's sisters
was adopting an iguana at the end of an
episode and what do we call it what do
we call it job job job and then yeah
your point
yeah it was proven that we will
eventually use everything uh i remember
to just off that joke because it ended
she's she's holding the iguana and
singing you look like an animator you
make me feel like a natural woman
because that was something no one will
ever forget the murphy brown episode
where she's got a baby
yeah we're paying tribute to this that's
right and here it is still running and
syndication and where's mercy's ground
where's that gag you know i know old
letterman bits for my kids you know it
might as well have been the hollywood
palace
very good family time
we're still here
in the jolly green giant it was funny no
references are like space junk they just
float you know they they burn out they
actually no face junk lasts quite a long
time but terribly i like her disneyland
last year and and i go to the current
version of the dapper dance who's saying
baby on board which is a song i wrote
for that episode you know and i just i
asked them anybody ever ask you guys to
sing baby on board and the guy goes
every day wow how about that it is nice
that's sweet they can never sing it
because
disney copy right exactly
but they
favorite songs in the show and i
mentioned that and one of the comments
that was funny is because i made a joke
saying it was capitalizing on the
barbershop craze of the 90s and somebody
said really there was a barbershop
oh my god you really have to watch what
you say especially about tracey ellman
yeah
as well you know i showed up uh what's
up man i show up at like three four
years in i can't remember i had been on
saturday live i leave
and i actually left cenote live without
a job
and then um i think you guys called me
up because you heard that maybe i was
can we tell you how we met you
originally we had heard that there was
this uh
yeah
that was the president of the lampoon
which is a real rare harvard lampooner
thing usually juniors get elected and
wow i heard this guy's really funny so
we went back and we knew your name was
conan o'brien very irish and i'm irish
but you've served at dinner only
potatoes yes and i thought this these
dinners were traditionally like lobster
you know you were supposed to and and uh
it was like angela's ass
we thought it would be funny just uh it
wasn't you know to be fair it wasn't
even my idea it was just someone else
and so you guys showed up and you were
so mad because you were hungry and you
held a grudge against me for years you
were like we just got these miserable
potatoes yeah but you weren't i want to
tell one more story which is we called
the lampoon first then we're talking to
you and he said my name's conan and
we go into the oldest jokes in the world
oh conan where's your sword oh conan did
you sacrifice babies
i remember said hey karm where's your
broad axe and he goes i don't have a
broad axe but i've got al brodak's the
producer of popeye
and i go wow what a reference i was so
impressed such an obscure dennis miller
reference yeah you made it but you saw i
think you sort of knew i'd get it right
now obscure references the star trek
the gore what is the gorb yes so anyway
but but you know we had met you and you
were incredibly impressive well
i was very nervous because i had never
written uh i had only written sketch
format before and and so
my first day uh and i've mentioned this
story to people before but my first day
you had
like taken a leave or you had left you
took a little break
they gave me they put me in your office
so i took over
your office and i'm there about like 15
minutes
when i decide that i should leave the
office and go and get a
a coke or something so i leave the
office when i'm out of the office i hear
a
smashing of glass sound and i ran back
and there was a hole in my window and a
dead bird a bird had hit the window hit
the wall broken its neck and was dead on
the floor and it like twitched for a
second and then died and just then
george meyer
walked by and he looked just peeked in
and he hadn't even greeted me yet he was
like bad sign man
i threw that bird
it can be told
we had hired conan and i think it was
like the first guy we had hired so we
were very protective and there was a
story retreat so we said you know tell
us what you're going to pitch before and
you came in with the monorail idea right
that's like oh god that's too crazy
we're gonna you know so don't pitch that
last and so then you sold two stories
which you normally only get one through
and then so i said well maybe try that
and then everybody goes we love that mom
no it's funny i was petrified with that
meeting we met at a hotel and there's
there's a gong and and jim brooks was my
first time meeting jim brooks and he's
there and then it's my turn and i pitch
a story and he he liked it and he's got
that distinctive jim brooks laugh and it
gets a gong
and then he said what else he got so i
pitched another story and they liked
that and then i i i it was like you're
being in vegas you're like you're hot
let's go for it the only guy that still
has cleared three in one day and then
and then i said the monorail episode
which just came from riding i was living
alone in an apartment and i was just
driving back and forth and i remembered
one day seeing a billboard
that just said monorail on it and i
think it was
it was a national transportation like
let's raise awareness of build of
monorails as possible and then the idea
started to cook in my head we get joint
credit on the monorail song which is
really funny because no he he
you wrote all the lyrics
and you
many of our songs were inspired by
others
and i remember we were real happy we
were coming in and reading it was like
yeah that is it was very funny and and
uh so you wrote the lyrics i went in
untouched and it was like it was i was
charged with writing the music yeah i
was like
i'm done
[Laughter]
50 50 collaborations
[Laughter]
one of the biggest misconceptions about
the simpsons
and this again this is from people
coming up to me is they after 20 years
of working in this other end of the
business they'll come up to me and
they'll say don't you it must have been
so glamorous to work at the simpsons and
i will tell them this room's more
glamorous yes i will tell them you have
no idea
how shitty the room was
uh meaning just literally physically it
was like we were we were writing this
brilliant show that's a huge success it
must be bringing in tons of money
and we were
writing it in like a flop house
literally a place like like a heroin den
[Laughter]
no no no it's nicer than he said no the
thing is it really isn't it's hard to
describe how unimpressive that room is i
mean the furniture was disgusting and
also i a lot of times sat next to
schwartzwelder and he chain smoked and
this was like an era when people act
like i'm describing the 1950s he had his
ashtray right here and he would chain
smoke the whole time all the smoke going
right into my face and it feels like
something out of mad men now but it was
i don't know it was 19 lighting terrible
at night at night it looked like a
seance it was that sad it was dark and
gloomy my wife brought our daughter who
was like two at the time do you even
remember this i remember perfectly they
were dressed they showed up they were
wearing like matching sundresses right
and and it was just wrong and being
there and we're sitting there and
we wouldn't we would have unlit
cigarettes in our mouth and we were just
a pale group you know and and my wife
that night said like i'm never going
there
what
a clear memory i have is
because the show was internationally
such a success there were always film
crews that wanted to come and i remember
one time when this film crew came from
germany and the guy or i don't know
belgium or whatever and he came and he
wanted to shoot us in our real process
and he went he said i'm going to shoot
the writer's room and simpson said i'll
i'm going to shoot this he said i want
you to just do what you do cinema verite
just do what you do so what we did
was sat around and sometimes sometimes i
honestly think 10 minutes 10 actual
minutes would go by of everyone quietly
thinking of what marge could say
when she and then one of us would go
like i don't know she could say
you know and then
everyone would not respond and we would
just go back to doing this and so this
guy after about 15 minutes of this
said i'm sorry but can you move around
because he wanted it to be
the dick van dyke show concept of a
writer's room where we're playing the
piano we're doing schtick we're jumping
around and it wasn't that but at me it's
like the heisenberg principle when you
observe it it completely vanishes again
exactly
the heisman
[Music]
that's the thing that people say what
was it like you said like it was sitting
in a room
for like 11 12 hours a day yeah same
spot but except i also thought
if you took a time lapse photography of
the three years i was there it'd be like
you know it looked like it would look
like a still picture
except the third year there would be
this
blur darting around and that was common
yeah yeah i had one i had not i was
incapable of sitting still and also had
the constant need to try and
you know uh
i had to move and i had to act things
out and i had to uh i don't know if it's
a sugar imbalance or a pituitary problem
but it got to the point where i would
there was one thing that i did for you
guys which is i would there was more
than one there was one
but there was one where i would fill my
mouth with coca-cola
and then start twitching
and vibrating and the coke would foam up
in my mouth and spill out like foam and
i would do this thing and you guys would
call for it occasionally it'd be like
do that again chop chop and i would do
it there were a bunch i mean
there was a you remember the old do you
think this is good there was some old
trope where like a stern boss would go
do you think this is good well so do i
oh yeah yeah it's something that
fascinated you because it
i'm sorry on star trek
no there was this thing they would do
would be like someone would pitch an
idea and uh you know uh and and the guy
would go like you mean to chill
you think that's a good idea and the guy
would say yeah and just to have a
comedic turn the guy would say yes sir
well so do i well i brought that up
because the bit became for you to put
more and more space between the two
halves yes yeah so
finally one day you really did go like
then you
made your face per purple yeah you
really think that's a good idea no i
mean you you just really threw yourself
into it and then well so do i and i
remember we just went ahead and applaud
you know we didn't generally applaud
it's like i was a performing champion
yeah it was uh i was afraid who's gonna
have an aneurysm or something so like
yes he's alive change the color of his
face
i will applaud you uh this is a uh
photograph i found from uh
from the time that i was there and you
like i remembered nothing in this room
they actually dressed it up yeah to make
it any of these guys are in there it's
always like put in these cutouts it's
potemkin village if i can use that term
but uh george meyer uh matt groening
john vidi there's jeff there's myself
there's
mr reece david stern david stern there's
you al and there's schwartzwelder and
there's the i'm not lying
actually i have a few bodies blocking me
in this one uh
and we would sit there and i remember we
would sit and we would the greatest part
of the day was when lunch would come and
one of the meanest things i ever did is
like pavlovian dogs
we would order the worst we would sit
still and then we would order from you
know island burger like these giant
hawaiian greasy burgers
and
we would sit in around 12 or 12 30.
we're all pitching but in the back of
our heads we know hamburgers french
fries are coming and the highlight of
your day yeah wrestle at the door and
what happened was it was that we were
kidding it was that we're not even k and
and there's a there's a metal screen
door and what would happen is the intern
always had such a full
box of burgers that he would kick the
screen door and it would kick open and
then he would back in with the burgers
and so one day we were waiting and it's
12 30 it's one it's 1 30 people were
starving and i just quietly got out of
the room and went and got a box
and kicked the door open and everyone
was like yay and then i came in with
nothing and you guys were like
we because all of you
yeah
when i hear wrestling styrofoam like
takeout boxes i have that reaction no
matter where i am i remember the show
was at it's well it's still at its
height but it was making billions of
dollars in t-shirt sales billions of
dollars in in uh uh
video all the every kind of ancillary
thing you could possibly imagine and the
head of production of 20th century fox
said you guys are having too many
pretzels yeah they came in and said yeah
no pretzel cut down on the pretzels into
soda it's like
you made a billion dollars this year i
had uh i auditioned for the late night
gig while i was at the simpsons
and improbably
got the job i mean i had no chance at
that job and a million things had to go
wrong it was like getting hit by a
meteor and i just came out of nowhere
and they called me in a simpsons record
and they said you now are going to
replace david letterman on the late
night show
and i
the first thing i had to do was buy
myself out of my contract
with the simpsons because they were like
well you oh you know we still have like
six months on your contract and people
were saying this is you know it's like
he got hit by a
no just let it go and they're like no
you owe this much no including the
people that ran the simpsons like jim
was going no no it's a great yeah no no
yeah jim was great jim actually gave a
sarcastic quote which was i've always
knew that conan o'brien would one day
replace david letterman as a joke like i
always knew that that would happen and
um it got picked up seriously by the
press and bought me some some street
cred for like three days
before you know literally people were
like well jim brooks said from the first
time he saw you you know and i'm like
yeah sure is this barbershop crazy that
lasts forever
i got the worst story of any of those
which was
i i i had to come into my al and i were
running the show we're working around
the clock and i had to come in with
pneumonia
and i sent a pa out to get cough drops
for 45 cents which is what they cost
then
and a couple of days later the line
producer calls me says what is this 45
cents for cough drops
and at the time this line producer had
like six weeks to live
and i'm thinking
maybe i can just wait the guy
i did i finally i just said this is a
good use of either of our times
that's incredible yeah one food we did
have butterfinger beeping yes i guess
there was a deal with yeah
uh butterfinger so we got these these uh
you know ice cream encased in butter
fingers that very very good for our
robots
but i remember it was another it was a
character you had of the butterfinger bb
man
who was supposedly the pitch man
for butterfinger bb they were just like
no not air can't get to me
you remember that's the butterfinger
baby man and and the idea evolved that
it that the kids just
hated but you were undaunted
right you were you you weren't daughter
it's like wow i know i'll do a rap
i'm the butterfinger man i'm here i'm a
terrible rapper i love butterfingers i
eat them every day
break it down yeah yeah
i think i was so
i don't want to i can't joke that i was
anything but grateful to you i'm serious
am i right just just for entertaining us
not so grateful he had some great
[Laughter]
david letterman but i did think oh
there's
there's other late night hosts to
replace
you'll have your crack
they're they're dropping like five
uh
going these five guys just keep
complaining about food
none of us don't look well well-fed i'm
sorry yeah
yeah
yeah
okay let me bring up something that i
think needs to be
discussed when i went to
uh
the simpsons i remembered i prided
myself on i'm gonna write edgy jokes i'm
going to be a joke machine
and when i got there you guys explained
this ethos the simpson has simpsons has
which is it's a family they care about
each other it's something that very much
came from
jim brooks and and maybe sam simon as
well but just this idea that this is a
real family and
when i first heard that i thought
yeah who cares about that i'm i'm here
to let's let's really bust through the
fourth
and and subsequently i've realized that
is probably the secret to the show's
longevity maybe we should talk about
that was that
was that really coming from
jim brooks do you think coming from all
of them i i'm matt greening too i mean
at a certain point it was like this is
not a cartoon we're making a show that's
not a cartoon it happens to be a cartoon
but it's not a cartoon now we
us youngans like the goofy cartoon jokes
and as silly as we could be but the
slightly uh whizzing older guys that no
approach it as a family and it was as
you say i think it's a genius i don't
know if it's the reason of longevity
because other shows like
family guy or what you know are going on
forever and they just seem to be joke
machines without any heart at all but
it certainly benefited the simpsons
because i think the the moments when you
know you have go-to moments of homer
who's
a complete
idiot right but cares about his family
he said okay i can i can watch another
episode of this no no that's why i
wanted to do that take the job was
turned down by a bunch of people before
we took it and the biggest attraction to
me was to work on a jim brooke show i
mean yeah
most of my favorite shows in the history
of comedy sitcoms are his and some of my
favorite movies yeah uh just a a
brilliant
guy and uh
seems to have an ear such a great ear
for
a certain kind of relationship between
characters
in the old days we would go to him
you know or we'd pitch out a story and
he'd give us one line and very often we
didn't even get it you know i was like i
feel what you see i think you know some
jim brooks like we go all right well
it's the boss we'll put it in and the
next day that was in every review of the
episode
the favorite line of women yeah every
time you came in one day
and you said i thought of the perfect
jim brooks line and it was you know what
i hate i hate the part of me that
doesn't love you enough wow
and it was so did you learn about
feelings and psychology but he didn't
have all that much time to give to the
show because he was running this big
entertainment empire so he'd come to
table reads and stuff and he he'd put
something in but he'd come to those uh
story retreats
we were talking about and i do remember
like the idea came up somehow like lisa
having a substitute teacher yeah that
episode dustin hoffman did the voice for
nhs
yeah yeah but but but i remember jim was
just like oh he's a good teacher and the
teacher has to leave and lisa at the
train station he gives lisa a piece of
paper and then she opens it and it says
you're lisa simpson he handed us the
page
he looked at it one by one and it said
you're lisa simpson so again we said
okay well it's great that's good
none of us would think of pitching
anything like that people loved it yeah
yeah and and when it all came together
that's your favorite episode right uh i
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really good
yeah
that's enough to say yes
you know what i'm forgetting
yes
i'm gonna superimpose my face over you
saying that's commentary yeah that's
your favorite
you should remember this anyway yes
everything on those commentaries is a
fact you know they're going to be some
people watching uh younger people who
don't know
jim brooks's lineage but we're talking i
mean spanglish yeah
like
mary tyler moore show which was uh
usually one of the great sitcoms of all
time
for the best ever yeah um taxi
which is in terms of endearment
phyllis these are good shoes so called
the associates which was but really
funny blue grant yeah i remember being
in college watching taxi in our dorm
room
and i'm watching the credit roll and i
go hey those are all the same names that
worked on the earlier jim brooks shows
and i recognize those things and i go
i'd love to be a part of that group i
remember thinking i'd want to be part of
that family and always working together
but i remember when that teacher one
came together and you know and we saw it
was really moving and i remember you
said
brooks knows more than all of us about
how to touch an audience so those early
episodes that had emotional heft
probably and in a car had a lot to do
with it and in the form of a cartoon it
meant even more i think and the fact
that you'd go to that length to sort of
bring some sort of emotional resonance
but i thought that's why it lasted but
well but it
there was a there was a hardcore rule
which is you know there's a lot of
cartoons that uh
where the impossible can happen you know
and you think about a wily coyote
cartoon where he can literally blow up
and then come back and he's he's
blackened or he's flattened like an
accordion and they were it was always
made very clear to me that that this is
a real world and it gets stretched
obviously it gets stretched like crazy
homer can fall down uh fall off the
cliff
but they make it very they make it very
clear that he's very badly hurt when
leonard nimoy zapped out on the monorail
episodes
i remember we were thinking we're
crossing the line yeah i remember i
remember being
real i remembered uh thinking i
remembered hearing i was thinking you
ruined everything yeah i've never had
time to go into my it's not like
gilligan like yeah i remember
wanting leonard nimoy to beam out and
saying you know and and and people
saying
that's not gonna happen matt's not gonna
let that happen the word's gonna get out
it's not gonna happen and then it it
happened and uh
forever ruined the show
well the the cliff one was a big
controversial thing because
which episode was that the bart the
daredevil yeah and and and
i think it was matt who was really
against homer falling down a cliff
because rightfully he didn't want his
show to be perceived as a goofy cartoon
that uh and so we we animated they
animated it one time with him hitting
the rocks hitting the rocks and i think
the compromise was he got bloodier on a
reanimation they put more red
they did it again and put more red on it
it is people's favorite little
sequence in the history of the show
though
it just keeps falling
it was very converse at the time i agree
i think to his credit years later matt
listed as one of his favorite things
um let's talk about sam simon sam was
when i got to the show
uh he was around a lot and
just an absolutely compelling figure i
mean he would come in he could
brilliantly funny he also intimidated me
i think i was lucky i he he liked the
cut of my jib so he went easy on me but
i could i could tell sometimes he'd come
in in a bad mood and
it was like the sixth sense you could
see your breath
he was
very uh and and
brilliantly brilliantly funny guy and i
was curious he i was surprised to find
out later on that sam had helped in the
design of the characters he had had
animation experience yeah but he redrew
he drew all of them i believe his dad's
name sam's is montgomery oh yes and um
yeah he's bro
he redrew bart and he redrew homer and
from the from the from the animated from
the tracy omen animated version he drew
a lot of these things he drew bartman i
think was his drawing um and and he had
cleveland comes too he had experience in
animation he worked for the fat albert
show not only was this guy who did uh
taxi and cheers but he had this great
background in animation so he actually
knew
what he was doing he was a bit of an
artist himself so
he he had a great sense of style and a
great sense of between him and matt and
matt i think matt generally felt like
that was his purview the the animation
aspect of it but but sam knew a lot and
made the show
really spectacular in a lot of ways and
and
the style of the show has a lot to do
with sam as well as matt
the other thing i remember about sam we
i think it was you and me and matt and
sam
writing the telltale head right yes
we're writing it in the room and
sam is sort of leading the writing and
he's just sort of going along he never
looked at pages as we were writing and
he just had the sense he goes and here
we go and we're going to get to the last
scene and it's over
and then they print up the script and it
was 45 pages it was exactly the right
length and the acts were in the right
place and i go how did he do that he was
just such an and it took three days i
think it was very quick to write and it
read
[Laughter]
and uh
i think chief wiggum and eddie and lou
are it was like 10 big characters came
in and this thing that sam sort of led
that we just started we never even
worked late but it was just three days
work
yeah he's amazing but and and that i
guess he was also trained in that that
was the style of which people wrote and
we were writing back then at the
beginning i don't think we had computer
screens or anything like that so it was
just you would listen
and jim brooks was very good at just
dictating
this happens and this happens there's a
seven and the character says this and
then you take a pause and then you say
what the rest of it was and it would be
great you know well i would say not me
and so when we were running it we did um
the opposite where we would just
continually rewrite it i would never be
sure and you know i mean everybody in
that show and jim and matt and sam and
all of the writers were great i mean i
don't use that word a lot but i would
say about everybody then but we would
just continually change it and it used
to be after the animatic you didn't
rewrite it that much but we would change
it more and make it denser and i think
that's one of the things that people now
expect is that the show is just like got
layers and layers
you know also with the budget increasing
we could do better yeah i mean it was
amazing because you do it but they did
it then too which was the the rewrite
process from
the
outline from the first pitch to the
outline to the second draft of the
outline to the draft to the second draft
to the room rewrite to the read through
and then they cut it together you get to
listen to it like a radio show and
decide which jokes aren't working then
then the storyboard you guys said well
this works and this doesn't and change
the storyboard and then change again
when you have this sort of first
animatic and change again when the color
comes back and you can put jokes into
people's mouths that's something people
don't realize the mouth movements are so
imprecise that you can change a line
days before it airs if if they're if
it's necessary there was one a joke we
had about the soviet union when the show
came back the soviet union had broken up
and so
that was our greatest fear throughout
the sanctions i think as long as the
soviet union holds
we have a show credit us with breaking
up this one we're trying to get a joke
for george bush uh
the first uh because he had 16 years
he had just dissed us uh and said why
can't they be more shows like the
waltons yeah and then we we had already
aired we wanted that week to put a joke
on and i forgot what the joke was but we
put it in his mouth so we're like the
waltons we're praying for the end of the
depression too and i just wanted to say
one thing just writing was kind of
seriously was i think one thing that
simpsons had an advantage on is that a
lot of shows that are live you tape
something during a week and you're just
you've got it and you can't really
change it but when you see something
three months later that you've written a
lot of things that you thought were
funny you go that isn't so good and then
you can fix them and i love having that
perspective several times over the
process of writing it you know like i've
been on live shows and sometimes you
just go oh this thing is great and it
isn't so great you know but you don't
realize it that week i think uh
he's sitting right there
he's sitting right there
[Laughter]
right
yeah these half dozen pale comedy
writers not my dream
the audience i got what i got and i'm
gonna work them they get a show no i did
i
i went when i got the late night show i
would entertain i would go up after the
show was over and the writers were there
late and i'd go into the room and i'd do
45 minutes
like why can't you go home i can't if
there's people around i need to go and
be an ass in front of but i remember you
were doing stuff at the groundlings back
then yeah and you'd had like a great
show and you came in the next morning
and you were just you were still high
about it yeah
you were real excited right and all that
and it was happy for you and i just sort
of felt well uh we got to think of
something for him
you and your front runner is dope yeah
when we were running the v-ray room they
could be looking over at the script and
i'd turn back and you guys would be
doing something you had a thing where
you were imitating star trek special
effects where you would go like this as
if like the ship was being
like an angry father
driving a station wagon
uh you know we should mention it
you know
there are there were limitations i
wanted to keep this to be a small group
uh and i wanted it to be a a small group
of people that i worked with when i was
uh
at the at the simpsons a ton of writers
that aren't here right now that have
just added immeasurably to the show that
probably are you know just great exactly
this is mainly i think
this is it should we should mention
george meyer yeah yeah yeah because i
well i always
you know people he's pretty legendary of
course and all that and the way i'd
always put it was like if we were a
baseball team and a really great joke
was a home run
i i think george hit the most yeah that
i think i wouldn't know his second but i
thought he hit the most that's he was
great i mean john vidi is great and
george was great and she worked well
schwartzwelder i think this works
yeah we always
get back for plugging his books on the
commentary but he writes books that are
available on amazon that are really cool
he i remembered uh schwartz welder
uh pitching
um
the episode the itchy and scratchy movie
episode where uh and you know that that
bart no no it was not that one i'm
trying to remember who was the there was
a movie that was coming
yes i wanted to see it and homer
wouldn't let him yeah and uh i remember
him i think he was pitching that and
just me sitting there like listening to
this pitch this is you know he had such
a great left brain
he's a unique brilliant guy when liz
taylor did the show i remember
schwartzwelder meeting liz taylor which
just struck me
yeah well schwab has shoulder-length
hair but otherwise kind of looks like
clark gable so yeah i remember her i
wondered
i guess i guess we're almost done you
remember when she went up to david
silverman after they were just screwed
she went up to summer and she just goes
where did those blue eyes come from
it was something i mean because like 300
people came to see liz taylor and she
recorded holding a dog like focus she
zoomed right in on silverman
handsome guy
i was uh
okay guest stars uh i was there the
highlight for me was johnny carson came
in
and recorded and i'll i can remember
everything i remember his car
the white corvette i remembered he came
in i remembered it was the most i was it
was would have been maybe about a year
after he
left the nine months after he left nine
months and um we didn't realize he
wasn't i think he he did this he never
really did anything else but he so it
was a really special moment to be there
and he came in i'll never forget he had
a filofax and like two packs of
cigarettes
sunglasses he came in
uh shy and i got to meet him a few times
subsequently but kind of quiet and shy
but then i could tell he really liked
being in a room full of comedy writers
and he opened up and he started telling
stories about bob hope he started
telling i mean just great and we sat
there and we had a stack of things we
wanted him to sign he signed everything
he was the ironic thing is we worked for
him for a year and a half that's right
you would work we only saw him maybe
twice
in the tonight show with james
comey writers and back then yeah no i
said i said he's aloof just you guys
beware and afterwards you guys look at
this like you're out of your mind he's
supposed to be an introverted guy yeah
he was never impolite he was it was
just like
he was going through a bad divorce when
we worked for him and then
he married a woman
20 years younger than him and hey it
made him a happy guy well i think also
happy years he was heading into court i
think he was also missing i think he had
he had not been doing he'd been doing
the show for 30 years i think he'd been
gone for nine months he came in and it
was a obviously were incredibly
respectful and in all of him but he also
i think he liked
i think he liked being in a room with
comedy writers and
we we were a great audience and i think
he had a i i really sensed he's having a
good time here he came in with a
monologue he came in yeah because i
remember the emmys were the night before
and he walked in and did like four jokes
about last night's emmys and it was sort
of like i'll i always opened with the
monologue
i thought he was the most charming man
i've ever met that's my answer to the
question and then i felt i i felt
bad because i was i had i was leaving i
thought he had left already
or he had left and i was leaving to go
back to the uh writer's room for some
reason and he was in his getting in his
car his white corvette and he just said
uh
excuse me could you tell me
how do i get off the lot which is the
way out
and i froze and i just
said words to
so i just said you go down here and you
take a right and he went thank you very
much and he you know take care and he
drove off and i saw his white corvette
take a right and disappear around the
corner and just as it did i was like
[ __ ] it's left the right yeah like it
comes to a dead end and i just panicked
and i'm and i'm like i just i'm standing
there
should have i felt i had i had one i had
a 50 50 chance
i could have and i've i said the wrong
thing and so i see this car
his car go right and disappear and then
this this i don't know agonizing weight
and then i just see the car come back
the other way
i just pictured him being like
stupid carrot tub
that was your milk jfk moment yeah
his career is over well see the dead
person yeah
i'll see to it that he never graces but
we went over to uh bob hopes yes that
was big when he uh we wrote jeff and i
went and recorded at bob hope's house we
met him it did if somebody if you're
pretty sure they can't see or hear you
does that does that count as meeting
them yes it's still counted yeah it
counted but i remember we went to the
kentucky fried chicken in toluca lake
beforehand before going over to bob's
house and you spent the meal speculating
uh what would what would happen oh yes i
remember this well that's just my
favorite thing is what's the worst thing
i could do you know it was just like so
what would actually happen if i like got
up in bob's face and went
you know
and then we had how do you make a living
now no but you know what yeah you had it
right you said
bob would leave the room and someone
else would come in and escort me out you
had like a very like you've seen that
yeah
over
it was for his line was uh dropped me
off of that boat show it was he yeah he
had a few ones he had a few lines
uh what what other favorite michael
jackson was a michael jackson yes
star what was the big story about that i
remember is we go we wrote the script
form and by the way again we wrote
it was like a 20 page single space out a
single space outline
we sent it to them and
you know that is an unreadable document
an outline for an episode and he read it
and he had a couple he added a couple of
great jokes she's a prince joke to elvis
i remember and uh
so we we have a rehearsal and what was
his manager sandy gallon
we go to a manager's house for the
read-through which we never do this is a
very unusual height yeah and then the
script hadn't been read so i was a
complete nervous wreck and of all the
rich people we've met i never heard this
where sandy gown says i haven't been in
every room of my
house but michael he reads the script
michael jackson laughs and he sings i'm
sitting right next to him he sings
thriller he sings ben
okay so we get to the recording
he's he's doing his lines the guy is
sort of impervious to direction or
acting he's not a good acting it's time
for him to do the singing and
he motions and this little white guy
comes in this tiny guy kip lennon the
brother of the landon sisters i'm sure
your audience loves the landing system
oh yeah and that was it and this guy is
michael's authorized sound alike he did
all the singing and that he brought a
sound of the sound of the show that's
who does the singing for michael jackson
it's kip leonard yeah
there was speculated that he had a
contract with cbs records that was kind
of iffy and then he please don't mention
because he also didn't
go by michael jackson in the show right
he had a nomination john jay
so it wasn't clear as to why he wasn't
doing it but it was clear that it was
very weird he wrote the song too he
didn't sing it maybe he was a little
eccentric
one thing i want to tell the monorail
story too because we're talking about
leonard and the boy he was not our first
choice first
choice was george takei george takei
who'd been on the show we said all right
let's bring him back he's great and i
did a passable george takei impression
which i used to wheel out all the time
and george the k turned the episode down
we said why he goes i don't make fun of
monorails
i think they're very serious i don't
want to make fun of them he was on the
transportation transportation board in
san francisco and he
didn't think someone should we we went
to the only actor in the world who took
monorail seriously
and he was like no we can't do it so
then i thought we're screwed and then
leonard nimoy said i want to do it i was
like i'll
let her demo spock out ranks yeah that
is trademarks decay yeah that is trading
um
this happened a few times but a few
times where there's somebody we didn't
think we could even ask and they said
yes but the first choice
i'll tell one and you can tell me to cut
it which was
lyle lovett wanted to be on the show or
you know who cares i love it but we
wrote him a part
he and we sent him the script he goes no
thank you
[Laughter]
we replace lyle lovett with pierce
brosnan who was james bond at the time
and it's like how often does that happen
no there's another one i don't remember
who was the first choice but elton john
was the second choice and i was like i
and i got to direct him and i couldn't
believe it the uh i remember we're
trying to get for the well episode bruce
springsteen yeah to see he's never done
the show who's never well uh he's got
there's almost nobody who ha yeah this
must be a very short list who hasn't
been the us president i saw bruce when
we were trying to get a hold of him we
were calling john landau i guess was the
manager and said
i think bruce may do it he was like
stringing us along
i saw him at the century cedar theaters
bruce springsteen was coming out of the
century city theaters
and i thought i can i can get bruce
springsteen at least he gets those
springs yes or no
of bruce springsteen so i i ran up to
him where i was wearing my simpson
jacket we had this
jacket not realizing
he thinks people attack him or he thinks
he's afraid of people you know somebody
shot john lennon you know it said it's
scary so i ran up to him and said bruce
bruce and he
shielded
his
paddy i guess was his wife at the time
and i said i'm a producer of the
simpsons like a crazy person
you must listen to me
why didn't you say something we're
trying to get you for an episode of the
simpsons and we've been calling your
manager and said oh yeah yeah yeah
that's that sounds great yeah i'll
definitely do
i
it i thought he was not i thought he
actually believed me not that i was a
crazy person but then we wound up
getting sting which was fine
i got to fly to new york and meet with
sting wow i i like sang him the harmony
part
to send in our love down the well and uh
that was so funny because we at that
the animated part is uh that we've got
sting but krusty is doing all right
[Laughter]
and i said this thing do you want to do
something and he goes i think krusty's
got it
we had written it for springsteen
because he goes like something like it's
about a kid down a well or something so
we had sing sing the same line and he's
like it's about a kid down a well or
something
we didn't even change the line
what uh
there was a phenomenon when i was
working there which was that we were
making homer i think was
boredom but we were also just trying to
push the boundaries
we were making homer stupider and
stupider and stupider to the point where
i remember there was one episode where
he
his brain tells him
if you
do this stupid thing i'm leaving you and
then he does it and the brain says
that's it i'm out of here and you hear
walking footsteps in a door slam meaning
his brain was so angry with his
stupidity that his his consciousness
left him and i thought
i don't think we can go any further like
it's that's the blue black at the edge
of the atmosphere but i mean i do think
we we used to sometimes question like
guys we gotta
we gotta tone it down he he needs to
carry on respiration of having your
brain leaking
choking up thinking about
church groups to this
episode al and i wrote a joke where
there's a guy standing in front of a pet
shop and he goes who what is that
horrible smell and then homer walks up
and homer was smells worse than a pet
shop and i remember it was a rendering
plan what well maybe we did that as well
gosh i think it was the best so homers
that would well george meyer goes oh now
homer smith
yeah we were running running out of
i don't know
george george would write jokes that
just seemed so classic sometimes i
remember the the colonel homer when
homer goes to the redneck bar
and one guy says you know hey you let's
fight another guy says them's fighting
words
[Laughter]
just be like that seems have i never
heard that that sounds so classic
well the
uh
sam simon i don't know how much of this
is folklore or not but uh
george i guess on a was supposed to
write a movie for uh for dave david
letterman and
didn't want to write it or was goal
breaking or something and wrote this
just did a few uh
issues of a magazine today it would be a
blog but then it was like it was like a
little actually i think i have one army
man
and
uh came out with it and i guess sam i've
always heard that sam went through an
army man
to
hire some of the writers i mean this was
just as underground as it got in the
world of comedy i think he hired john
and john off of it john john
schwarzenegger george george i don't
know i'm not sure are you having
something something right but he didn't
hire me yeah not us we
we stood next to sam at a wedding
that's another way to do it
nobody on the original writing staff
except i think al and i nobody had ever
written a half hour script right nobody
had kids we're writing about family life
oh jim had kids
that's right otherwise it's a perfect no
jim and sam knew a lot about
sitcom structure well i i would find and
this was leads into the next thing i
want to bring up which is which
characters it was fun to write for
i stayed away because i was in my 20s
didn't even have a girlfriend at the
time and so i didn't want to write about
relationships i didn't want to write
about kids so i loved
really loved writing anything where
homer's stupid but i particularly loved
writing for burns i just loved to me
that was a place i could inhabit which
was there's anything can happen with
that character i thought it was a part
of the show
that
really allowed you to be completely
insane because burns has unlimited money
and his cruelty is a caricature
he can have robots he can have a
hyperbaric chamber anything can happen
but i'm just curious which characters
you guys have sorry about burns which
was i think every writer loves writing
for him because he's you know very
florid and he can do anything but
we were screening um the cable episode
the homer stealing cable and at the
screen he was getting huge laughs until
the second part where burns comes in and
then suddenly it just kind of died off
and i was like i think the writers like
him yes and then on the other hand i
know people love him and love him as a
villain but it it definitely
i think you know people that as i've
learned over the years it seemed to like
the family like no matter what if you do
one of the family members they go crazy
and i always liked writing for lisa
lisa's favorite do you think well
because i was most like lisa when i was
a kid you know sometimes bart would say
things my sister said in scripts that we
did but lisa was the one you know that i
thought was the i like writing for lisa
because brooks would approve those
scripts like you know it wasn't easy
it was an easy in to get at the story
meetings if you've got a marge or a list
when you pitch like lisa the bart friend
right
[Laughter]
i remember thinking uh i was struck
immediately with what a good actress
yardley was because i think like real
early on it's like well i guess lisa's
sort of laughing and crying at the same
time on this line and yardley okay
like first time it's like wow
people would really connect yeah the
substitute episode i mean david go oh my
god and she'd start crying as a cartoon
character they would just it was it's
amazing she was touching and it wasn't
hard for her i mean she always seemed to
do it right first time everything
there's something that's hard to explain
to people
the vocal quality of these actors
uh
makes the
really just brings that show to life and
when you think about it you just think
it's people doing voices how
how could it be but it doesn't exist
without those actors they really do it's
it's it's very imaginative and people
like dan and harry and hank are doing
multiple characters talking to
themselves i mean when people at table
read i'm just always like worried about
how the script's gonna play but people
who come to them it's like a magic act
they will go that's what you know i was
at a gym and a guy next was going i went
to a simpsons read it was the most
amazing thing i ever saw because they
they really do they just transform and
i've also burns and smithers scenes yeah
our harry shearer talking to himself he
switches voices back and forth yeah i've
never seen him slip up
i've had them on over the years late
night guest and it's just amazing to
watch it never fails
they'll come out
they'll sit down
and the minute one of them does the
voice
it's beatle mania in the room well
grandpa i to me is such a fun voice just
because he's just so angry all the time
and i there was i bring it up because i
know it just killed you at the time one
episode where homer's life flashes
before his eyes and it goes back to when
he was a boy soprano singing oh holy
night
and greek you go to grandpa in the
audience and he goes what a voice young
homer is going to make me a millionaire
i remember that just endlessly amused
you because grandpa was calling him
young homer
apparently to clarify things in case
someone ever watches this in flesh
and i i gravitated towards all the
ancillary characters it was like preston
sturges you know like what's really
funny is those you know wigan saying
this and lionel hutt's saying that and
it's like having that full world to draw
upon is i think that's what's amazing
about this one thing i remember is the
three of us jeff and mike and i and
george were doing the rewrite on that
cable show and we were trying to really
love phil hartman we were trying to
think of an old uh actor so that was
troy mcclure where we came up with him
at that rewrite and it was troy downey
he was doing his first old uh old movie
the first time he cited his credit yeah
here comes the coast guard and stuff
like that and you know the story it was
we know troy mcclure is named after troy
donahue and doug mcclure
doug mcclure was a fan of the simpsons
and he's watching at home with his kids
and troy mcclure comes on
and he says those kids are they making
fun of me and they watch and
his kids go yeah i think they are dead
and he watches a little more he goes
that's pretty funny
it's amazing how for a guy who was never
conceived in the dna of the show and was
just like a thrown in character how much
people missed him once he was gone it
was uh
you know the show was never about this
actor who comes on late night tv during
commercials
but but that's how great he was but you
remember him i had worked with him i
worked with him for years on sarah live
and he was just yeah just
but always kind of in character yeah the
phil i knew
phil was always phil meaning phil would
come in and i'd say hi phil and he'd be
like keep him flying boys
at the table he'd come to the table
reads and we'd always say and hey a big
simpsons welcome back to phil hartman
and while we were plotting he'd always
go it's about the work
yeah
he was always on he was always
encountered every time he was on the
phone
he goes i'm going to put phil on the
phone he goes how you doing now
it was never different yeah it's what's
also interesting about phil was is you
know inside out live people kind of
assumed he was the master of a thousand
voices but he only had one voice yeah
just you know he put different costumes
on and have the same voice but on the
simpsons you know troy mcclure and
lionel hutz they sounded pretty close
they were the same boys and then there's
an episode where they both appeared and
suddenly phil was on the spot and he's
trying he was trying to change one of
the voices and we're going that's not
how he talks but he was sort of busted
on that sideshow bob great uh
kelsey grammar kelsey grammer uh
the cape fear episode i remembered him
when we were when we were working on
that episode i just remember just his he
he's the perfect caricature of an
over-the-top actor well i remember the
act break with the one where he married
soma he said sleep well selma the you
know honeymoon was
tiring and the wedding was tiring and
the honeymoon will be
murdered and he drops his voice and he's
just got such a vocal timber yeah yeah
that you could like feel it in your
lower
um why uh has the show lasted so long
does anybody know i have to say i left
in 93 and i remember thinking it's you
know
they've done everything they can do
it there's nothing left to be done then
maybe they get another year or two out
of it and uh
not the case it has just it continues to
be great and it's just lasted how many
years has it been now we're going to the
25th 25th and uh i think everybody
that's worked on it has had the same
view which is
this is a special thing you know the
highlight of my career and the career of
almost everybody that's been there you
know
and i think you just go you don't want
to let people down you're so you know
enamored of this
show
and uh you know it's also animation
you're evergreen i mean you don't have
like bart would now be 30 and like
living in his parents home and it would
look really horrifying and and it's not
like those late brady bunches where
cindy is are they leave it to beaver
where lumpy rutherford is like 500
we don't have that it's still funny i
mean that's the bottom line is it's
still a funny very funny show my son
who's 11 is a huge fan i mean we've got
i got to watch all
all over again when my son became a fan
and uh
it they're still great they're still
really funny and
you guys you know they work really hard
at making it fantastic it's weird to go
back i must admit when i every now and
then i go back it's like going back to
college and seeing the people
have never left college they're still in
the same chairs i'm that creepy guy
when i was shooting something on the fox
slot for the emmys and i just went by
and i thought hey it's right over there
and i went up the stairs um and
it's
uh i mean wearing a sundress see i was
wearing a sundress yeah
i i went up the stairs and it's uh to
the to
the simpsons room and i like pushed open
the same screen door and
it was like opening up a like light came
in and people were like
it was a bunch of people i didn't know
actually it was a bunch of writers that
and i guess you would split the rooms
because you guys weren't mike scully to
damage i mean
yeah and then i remembered like our
duties
i screwed around for a little bit and
then i said well i better get going
they're like no no
stage
[Laughter]
no do you remember we had a tape of the
brady bunch variety show
with the swimming pools yeah yeah and so
much more
this was a terrible terrible show that
came out a few years after the brady
bunch was canceled and we would watch it
like in 10-minute increments during
lunch and it was like the highlight of
our day and we would we would analyze it
it's just like wait mr brady sent the
kids off to bed but it appears to be
light out and greg is well into his 20s
they're trying to get away with a
dramatic plot and then do a variety
segment like where they're working
they're wearing jumpsuits
they're wearing jumpsuits and bell
bottoms you know sort of elvis style and
they're doing these big dance numbers
but then the reality is that well he's
still an architect
and the kids have to be sent off to bed
but vincent price is there and and it
wasn't very carefully written
no it was it was very carefully crafted
we're here to talk about the early days
of the brady variety
became such a big hit oh right
uh all right i have a question here from
a fan
on a tablet this is called oh well you
know what these are because you're from
the
29th century
there you have it india boldware from
facebook asks have you ever thought
about the perfect way to end the show
well there's one story i can tell which
was um
we have a negotiation every four years
because you can't like enslave people so
the cast that the last one
uh you know fox said you have to be
prepared to end the show if
it doesn't work out and it did you know
they actually took a pay cut they loved
the show so much to keep it going but we
were going to end it in that case with
the christmas show in the future that
stuart burns wrote and that would have
been the last episode wow um but you
know the way i answered it is like i go
we've had a lot of episodes that could
have been great last episodes like
maggie talking
um
like the
behind the music parody uh and i go
there's no you know end in sight and you
know i i think when it comes it may just
be something like that where you could
go there's a bunch of different ways you
could end it one thing is
just to show you how far the show has
come even in the first season was matt
greening had a couple of ideas first
season for the end of the show and his
two ideas were
that we reveal that homer is crusty
and that was his idea and if you ever
see krusty without makeup he's homer and
it was gonna be that was one of his
reveals bart hates homer loves krusty
because they're really the same guy and
the other idea was and marge would take
off her hair
and she had long rabbit ears so that
would have been the last episode homer's
crusty and marge is a rabbit we get more
angry male than the last soprano
tv's changed so much so it doesn't
you i think sometimes it doesn't have to
be an end of the show like what would
stop the show from just going another oh
i mean like what stops saturday night
live i mean answer nothing right there's
another highest rated show on nbc you
know and i i we don't look at it that
way i mean um
you know
you know
with anything on television i assume it
would be money but um
you know it's still an international hit
and it's still
you know
i don't i don't know i mean you've
talked about it ten years ago yeah but
it is money like like
i think it's a lost leader to fox is
from what i understand i mean it's
expensive to make
they're still
claiming deficit spending and all that
uh you know all that all that kind of
stuff but it makes a night of
programming for
them that animation so well and it's
it's it's still
you know i was explaining this to my
daughter like you know i go we got a 2-2
and she goes what out of what and i go
well 100 and she goes so if i got a 2-2
that was a good number
welcome to tv and pays your private
school bills
shut up just shut up
um
we've been talking for uh god a really
long time i don't know if anybody wants
to add anything uh if you've got any
thoughts
i brought you here because one of you is
a murderer
[Laughter]
i actually just i did want to say at one
point that my writing partner wally
olidarski who couldn't be here was
invited yeah who was invited but refused
to come
but my experience my experience
obviously wouldn't be complete without
talking about my partner who you know
was as more insistent that we do the
simpsons than anybody i know he thought
he believed that that show was going to
be a huge hit and a certain point uh i
kind of believed but not like wally i
mean this was again it was our summer
job from
working on the lowest rated show on tv
it's just where any you know and if it
wasn't us it would have been seven other
guys i think it's just such a durable
project and such a great collection of
characters and casts and animators it's
a dream for writers i mean listen to be
able to write in a quarter of a page
you know
exterior football stadium for just one
joke and to be able to leave
is fantastic well i was going to say it
too that if it's a writer's paradise
thanks to jim you know
having those credits that he does he
never says why mr mary tyler moore do
this i mean it's
just the greatest thing where it's like
the greatest forum for any writer for
any writer's idea as you know having
been there i mean and it's like i keep
pinching myself i've been there 20 years
it's amazing jim said at the beginning
which is very interesting he said you
know when we were worried well this show
did that and that should the simpsons
can do anything they want it will be
different and when you do it as a
simpsons you have permission to do
anything that that you want to you don't
have to be afraid it'll be like anything
else because it won't be and he was
absolutely right
i have a personal feeling oh you go
ahead well i just uh wondered uh the
first
some one thing i wanted to say was the
first uh song i wrote for the simpsons
was capital city
that tony bennett uh saying there's a
line in it uh you'll caper like a stupid
clown when you chance to see fourth
street in d and in simpson's uh official
publication sense that's been
transcribed as yo gapa
like a stupid clown
which and i look like a very inept
lyricist
i couldn't think of a word that scanned
so you'd like to correct that i took
another word and just added a nonsense
every
it was amazing you just say hey jeff
could you just do a little like thing
and they did the whole street car
musical it was brilliant yeah okay
it was like really the capital city song
i was really happy because i was
insecure i'd never written
for a sitcom before and i guess you guys
hadn't much either i brought in the
capital city song and sam was very nice
and and said grand slam home run
and uh you just you feel sort of a
weight of insecurity
what a great drop off
tony bennett
singing it was amazing the hell out of
it i mean didn't that relaunch him he
we've talked about how it was hard work
but they were also like you'd
then alf clausen would write this great
nelson riddle arrangement and you have a
40 piece orchestra yeah playing this
song you wrote in a big recording studio
like with sinatra session and it's like
that's thrilling i got to we got to meet
beatles got to i mean
you met you were beaming the day you
came back from meeting george harris yep
i remember yeah it was great yeah i got
to meet john lovetts
the first year two we talked about but
the miserable conditions and
the hours were very long the first year
maybe into the second it was fun it was
fun i remember we'd get out at 5 30. we
do what we i'd never done on any other
show which is we'd all go out together
we'd all go see a movie we'd go see
batman the michael keaton batman you
know we went at midnight to go see that
we had fun it was a nice place to be
once you once described it you'd say
like it was a job you know you describe
it like pulling a big oar
to move something forward yeah but but
then again interspersed with great
i mean to this day
just such a magical
writer's room and i always say like the
yes it was pulling a big ore
interspersed with just moments where
you're crying you're laughing but the
thing that moved but what did move it
forward was everyone laughed yeah you
know so that restores you yeah
it was uh
um and also i think
really did it's such a
writer-driven show i mean animators
so many all the components had to be
right but the but
the writers were so respected on that
show and had so much power to create
their own world i've always thought too
when i watch live action now that
the simpsons influenced there's a lot of
quick cutting you know a lot of rock is
definitely tina fey said you want to do
a live action ship yeah i think it's a
trip what a great show yeah and and and
there's but i mean
other shows too i see them modified it
influenced the the culture so much you
know people thinking something seeing
their thoughts quick quick cutting back
and forth which uh
i don't know i just opened up a whole
new world another thing that was great
about it in those days even if it sounds
corny like the sort of three sides of
the triangle of the writers and the
actors and the animators i think each
group thought the other two groups were
doing a great job yeah oh those
animation guys
david silverman was the supervisor and
he called us and he'd go
you're killing rich moore you're giving
him so much stuff to do and then richard
go don't tell him i'll do it as like the
streetcar one everything we asked he did
that's right and and i mean this is
taylor yeah
[Laughter]
director who's a fantastic movie live
action director yeah no it's not the
incredibles or attitude three of our
early directors were nominated for
oscars and brad bird including including
david yeah
rich moore we'd go in and do the
animation and brad bird would give notes
yep four of them yeah brad bird would
give notes and at one point uh
you learned that when you tilt the
camera sideways like they did for batman
villains it was called a dutch angle
yeah yeah and you latched on to that i
love it and in every animatic uh
you know
in a dead spot you go i think a dutch
angle here
mesmer
yeah
i think it's clear that i did more to
hurt the simpsons and help it
uh well thanks a lot guys for doing this
this was a blast for more episodes of
serious jibber jabber go to teamcoco.com
sirius